my brother and i started a software
company which one uh solar winds
yeah you started solar yeah you know
very well yeah thanks that was dave yonz
the founder of solarwinds
announcing to the world on television
that he had poured more than five
million dollars into a company that
makes a 350
camping cooler this guy had just sold
his company for more than 4 billion
and was worth well over 100 million
dollars personally
the craziest part the sharks said no
so dave i don't think people in america
are going to embrace a 400
cooler with ice in it as an air
conditioner
and so for those reasons i'm out and for
that reason i'm out
i'm out i'm out
it's not every day that you see the
founder of a technology unicorn
pitching some camping gear on shark tank
especially when that unicorn just
happens to be responsible
for potentially the largest cyber
security breach in u.s history
i'm john coogan and today we're diving
into the solarwinds hack
i'm fascinated by this hack because i
know enough about programming to follow
along with what most likely happened
but to be fair i've never worked in i.t
at a large company
so i'm going to try and boil down the
key points in a way that anyone could
understand
i'll also link to other videos and
sources in case you want to go really
deep into how the hack
actually works let's start with some
history how on earth did the founder of
solarwinds wind up
on shark tank well it all starts in 1999
when dave yance and his brother
co-founded solarwinds in order to
productize
some software that would help big
companies monitor the performance of
their corporate networks
these types of services are important
for big companies because it allows them
to make sure the code that they write
and the applications that they deploy
are running smoothly even during peak
operating times and under heavy loads
if you've ever wondered why your
internet is slow only to realize that
your roommate was trying to download all
six seasons of the sopranos in the other
room
you understand one of the most basic
problems that solarwinds solves
in practice there are tons more places
where network performance monitoring is
important
and that's what led to massive growth
for solar winds in just the first decade
of growth
solarwinds added 450 employees raised
money from bain capital and insight
venture partners
and went public on the nasdaq all while
maintaining profitability
it wasn't long before they were
acquiring other companies with adjacent
products
expanding internationally and growing
their customer base into the tens of
thousands
and that's a big part of why the solar
winds attack was so successful
instead of targeting a specific u.s
government agency
the hackers went after solarwinds which
sells software
to u.s government agencies this is
called a supply chain attack
and it's becoming an increasingly common
attack vector essentially
supply chain attacks target app
developers who deploy code to a wide
array of companies
and inject malware into their app
updates these updates are digitally
signed by the originating company
so the recipient doesn't notice anything
wrong when they update their apps
this is particularly harmful because the
victim company is actually doing the
right
thing they're keeping their apps up to
date and this also enables attacks on an
unprecedented scale
compromise just one company and you can
effectively compromise them
all but hacking into one of these supply
chain companies like solarwinds isn't
easy
software is their core business after
all and they are aware of how important
their systems are to their customers
and that's why everyone immediately
assumed this had to be a state actor
most likely russia the patience and
attention to detail in this malicious
piece
of code is truly staggering if you're
technical
you can actually go and look at the code
yourself the hack
which is now being referred to as
sunburst was installed so widely
that developers have shared the code
publicly in order to enable the entire
cyber security community to work
together on a solution
i won't bore you with a detailed
analysis of the code but there are some
really interesting tidbits in there
first the hack is programmed to sit
entirely dormant for two whole weeks
after it gets installed
so even if you installed the update in a
quarantined environment and monitor it
24 7
you would have to wait two weeks before
you started noticing anything odd
and the hack is also aware of its
environment before doing
anything it checks to make sure that the
computer it has infected
isn't running any of the popular
diagnostic programs used by cyber
security teams
lastly when the hack does finally start
actually stealing data
it doesn't just copy all of the infected
computer's files and send them off to
russia directly
only small amounts of data are stolen at
a time and then the stolen data gets
encrypted
and then wrapped in legitimate data that
looks like normal analytics traffic
it's extremely common for applications
to send out analytics data to other
servers
so this looks pretty normal if you've
ever seen a little pop-up asking
would you like to share analytics data
with the developers of this app
you'll know what i'm talking about any
it professional at a large company that
got infected with sunburst
probably wouldn't notice data leaving
their networks because it looked
just like normal solar winds traffic
when small time hackers figure out a way
to break into a system
they usually don't have the patience to
build a bigger hack that could infect
more systems
the tech companies are constantly
hunting down exploits
so once you discover an exploit it's
only a matter of time until the company
discovers it as well
and patches the software putting you
back to square one
this is why you see a lot of hacks where
someone breaks into a company's servers
steals a bunch of credit card data and
then immediately starts charging those
cards
but state actors like russia can afford
to be more patient
the hackers working on this project
likely get paid on a regular basis
like any other programmer as opposed to
an independent credit card thief
that might be broke and just looking for
a quick buck signs point to this hack
first being deployed in march of 2020
but it's possible that they gained
access to solar winds even earlier than
that
but they just sat on it so if it was
russia what do they want with our data
well these hacks generally fall into two
categories
espionage and sabotage espionage is
basically a reconnaissance mission
the hackers are spying on united states
systems in order to better understand
our capabilities and vulnerabilities all
signs point
to the solar winds attack falling in
this category which is good news
because sabotage is where it gets really
ugly cyber attacks that seek to sabotage
can disable critical infrastructure
cause billions of dollars in damages
or even hypothetically launch nuclear
weapons now
i don't want to be alarmist obviously
the us government spends a
disproportionate amount of time and
money
trying to defer sabotage missions so in
theory they are less likely to happen
and these attacks don't happen in
isolation state actors understand that
if they are caught there will likely be
a response
so a spying mission like this one might
lead to increased economic sanctions
but detonating one of our nukes will
likely lead to all-out war
and nobody wants that but cyber attacks
aimed at sabotage do happen
and there's a lot that we can learn from
them in 2010 security researchers
uncovered the stuxnet virus
which was designed with the explicit
intent of destroying iranian nuclear
centrifuges
much like the solar winds hack stuxnet
was designed to lay dormant until it
landed on a specific target computer
but computers at iranian nuclear
facilities are air-gapped
meaning there is no access to the
outside network so they couldn't send
data out of the facility
but that wasn't the goal of stuxnet
instead of merely collecting information
the stuxnet virus would slightly change
the speed at which
centrifuges would spin so when the
infected computer would send a signal to
the centrifuge to spin
at the precise speed in order to
maintain stability the virus would
slightly alter the signal
in order to change that speed this
ultimately destroyed almost
one-fifth of iran's nuclear centrifuges
significantly setting back their nuclear
program
crossing an air gap is no easy feat
since computers on an air gap network
can't pull updates from the internet any
code that runs in the facility
must be physically carried in but the
hackers behind stuxnet
had a solution to this problem they
scattered usb
drives in the parking lots where they
knew contractors who visited the
facility would stop
after a curious contractor picked one up
thinking it was maybe just a free usb
drive
or maybe had some interesting data on it
they would inadvertently infect their
own system
it's possible that this is how hackers
first got access to solarwinds
infect one employee's laptop and when
they come into work
they will infect the rest of the network
but we don't know yet
there is another way that hackers gain
access to private networks
and this technique is surprisingly low
tech they just pay off a disgruntled
employee
this almost happened earlier this year
to tesla but the plot was foiled
a russian came to the u.s and tried to
pay a tesla employee 1.5 million dollars
in order to knowingly infect the tesla
network using a usb drive
the tesla employee contacted authorities
but you can see
how this strategy would have been even
easier than trying to hack the company
directly
so what's the takeaway for entrepreneurs
obviously
if you're going to be selling software
to lots of companies you need to build a
strong culture around cyber security at
the earliest stage possible
state actors are more motivated than
ever and it's only a matter of time
until they set their sights on you
but more generally i think it's
important to make sure that your
employees are happy
as we saw with the tesla example things
could have gone a completely different
direction
if that employee really hated his job
and wanted to hurt the company
more broadly gone are the days of
thinking about warfare exclusively in
terms of missiles and ground troops
there are three types of warfare
informational economic
and kinetic the united states has been
able to avoid direct kinetic warfare
with any of the major global powers
since world war ii
but increasingly economic warfare in the
form of trade deals tariffs and
sanctions
have played a huge role in international
stability now we are finally starting to
see the full scope of the informational
cyber war that has been going on for
years
as an entrepreneur global stability is
extremely important
i want to be able to do business
anywhere in the world without the fear
of a relationship between
two countries devolving to the point of
business disruption
so i hope that the solar winds hack
leads to more defensive cyber security
measures
as opposed to an aggressive retaliation
that could escalate things further and
what about dave yantz
the co-founder of solarwinds who's now
the owner and inventor of the icy breeze
cooler
what about him well i think there's an
important lesson in there too
we know he's rich enough to never work
again and he has the credentials to go
start another it company at any time
so why is he on shark tank i think he's
just having fun
he's made his millions but loves
tinkering and inventing things
even though he got turned down on shark
tank going on tv was probably still a
fun experience
and they probably sold a bunch of those
coolers as soon as the show aired
and perhaps most importantly there's
zero risk that a cooler
will cause information about u.s nuclear
weapons to fall into the hands of the
russians
i think he got out at the perfect time
and he's probably unbelievably happy
that he doesn't have to deal with this
whole stressful mess that solar winds
right now
but let me know what you think in the
comments are you going to start taking
cyber security more seriously after
watching this video
if you're interested in learning more
about solarwinds i've put together a
youtube playlist and we'll link it below
and if you enjoyed the video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching